we've got more pieces of the blades Oh
actually touch the name before this
we've got sexy Dylan and we've got DS
mustache what do you think this is your
bachelor in paradise episode 4 recap
grab your glasses it's time for roses
and Rose Bay hi babes it's me Lauren
what we have here every episode of
bachelor in paradise this season the
crew is stepping it up we got like a new
sexy color look at this look at that oh
it's like stormy stormy weather
hurricane Blake
hurricane Blake is still a thing in fact
it's now gone from like a category 4 to
like a category 76 okay let's talk about
it again I have a fun tropical glass
this time with ice because things got
hot in paradise this episode oh we got
some sexy guys in this episode and I
appreciated it let's get to it first of
all is he sexy I don't know Kevin We
Need to Talk About Kevin or do we
because I forgot Kevin was there until
the episode opened up with him working
out with that vase speaking of hot we
get freshly showered Dylan I love doing
with the wet hair wet hair don't care
but Dylan do care about women and being
supportive and kind and a wonderful
boyfriend
the only established couple right now
seems to be Derek and Demi
oh this one here's my question about
demi and Derek do you guys think this
will last we've seen on the trailers
that this woman who Demi dated in the
past is going to show up on the show so
I don't know about the future of the
double D I'm getting real D for deep
right off the top here but you know love
the d damn me and Derek did I just say
of the D it's paradise it's messy it's a
dumpster fire D for dumpster fire let's
go just like like I told them I like
boys and girls Demi also has this deep
discussion with her friend Katie and
tells her about being fluid being
attracted to both men and women and
having that discussion in that reveal
with her parents really good it was just
really hard and something I'm like
really scared to do for a really long
time
[Music]
they were just like your art Dems we
love you no matter what I love that what
did you guys think of this moment I was
legit crying but you know from really
sweet to a little savage drink every
time if someone was kind of mean in this
episode honestly at this point I'm kind
of confused at wideboys the hot
commodity among the women
that walking alone
who's getting a rose this week ABC
anyone but cam he's had a rough life I
think by the looks of it good have some
swagger great white shoes in the sand
disciple wise anything yeah it's just
weird but hey he's not a model B his
personality sucks and see he more
athletic shoes to paradise
like on entrance don't buy a pair of
espadrilles you thanks for savage what
do you guys think I do think sometimes
we have like our fan favorites you know
and that if other people like people who
are already villains we're saying some
of those things they would get way more
back rush hmm then we are reading more
chapters in the book of Blake
it is Psalm 750 thousand and twelve for
Blake okay we are deep actually texted
me before this and you're psyched so in
order like oh you
who I am I actually just booked a flight
to Birmingham we are now learning why
Hannah might be so into Blake we are
discovering the before paradise he
booked a flight to Alabama and hung out
with Hannah and this story is so weird
to me Ana's like he wanted to show me
who he was so he booked a flight to come
see me and we kissed like we kissed
there and I am in the airport what
happened
where were you how long did he stay
was it a one-way or was it a roundtrip
did you get dinner did he meet any of
your friends and family see your local
cause was this a hometown date I'm
confused
the paradise plot Monday night people
were turning on Hannah
and now Taoiseach is confronting Hannah
so it's Taoiseach versus Hannah and who
do you agree with Hannah right now is
the puppeteer tasia called Hannah the
puppet master
I don't think Hannah's being
manipulative because she's being upfront
with everyone she's not hiding from
Dylan that she's hanging with Blake you
know what I mean
[Music]
[Applause]
but then I breath of fresh Dean arrives
I don't know if in the past I would have
thought of Dean as a breath of fresh
what do you think but he's here in the
space with something on his face I think
that the moustache he's working for Dean
in fact I think it's perhaps doing
wonders for Dean Dean came in and talked
to Chris and I loved everything Dean had
to say
Dean is owning his truth it would move
out of Los Angeles I live in a van now
he is living in a van showering and
stuff as well running water for like
toilet his showering situation is
questionable
I don't really judge that I haven't
washed my hair days what did you think
of his arrival I'm calling this the
redeems in like redemption but Dan
okay I'm mustaches back so let this
thing happen with a blaze of stagecoach
I don't feel like anything we at Asia
versus Hannah now we also have at Kaelyn
versus Christina girl don't turn on each
other
Blake is the dumpster fire but you don't
need to fuel the flames
I was just sitting at the bar I
overheard Christina literally sitting
directly next to me talking to else
about me and Chris and I'm like
Christina is talking about Kaelyn like
literally right here like I don't know
how she didn't know that Kalyn was
sitting here like Christina is this
pillo and I am Kalyn and it's like she's
right there but Kalin says that
Christina is slut-shaming her really
frustrating
that's a big word what do you guys think
was that happening that bit of
Christina's conversation that we saw
didn't sound incredibly critical and
honestly if Kalin's definition of
slut-shaming is that christina was
talking about what happened between
herself Blake and Kailen Kailen did that
the past two episodes she was done
everybody that Christina and Blake had
hooked up so I don't see the
slut-shaming from being honest and then
an arrival I was less excited about
Christian drink every time someone said
that just gotta bring that Rico suave
yeah yeah so Becca Cooper in season and
he was most memorable for not wearing
socks at the men tell all but he's gonna
make some memories in paradise clay is
holding a football and Christian is
holding clays girl Nicole Christian
zeroes in on Nicole he seems to only
talk to her he takes her on his date Wow
Christian is Seifer confident
and there's another cc4 chemistry the
vibes on Christian and Nicole's date are
strong they are fiery and not in a
dumpster fire kind of a way moment she
said yes to be on a day like this game
over sorry boys but there is such a
thing as to cot banks and Nicole wants a
guy who's aggressive but there is such a
thing as too aggressive and Christians
giving me let out lives but also red hot
flags you know and we know where this is
gonna go okay probably somewhere between
Christian and Clay's levels of
confidence and aggressiveness is the
right mix you know nobody's perfect
this is my third day by the way drink
for every time Nicole is feeling
ourselves not gonna lie you're with a
hot commodity I believe the best like
guys could be potentially fighting over
me cloud9 I feel like I'm the
Bachelorette of paradise good for you
girl enjoy it you know life's hard
enough so given the good stuff
he's a good-looking guy he's like east
straight out of a soap opera I feel like
they could have some serious chemistry
and that's I think that is a threat to
my relationship so Christian Nicole come
back from their date and clay just want
some time with the woman who he thought
was his girl so he goes and talks to her
but then Christian comes over and then
Christian and clay engaged even
arguments while holding hands there's a
Louis's warning I literally I literally
just walked in here and it is one of the
weirdest things I've ever seen
drink for the entire time that they are
fighting with each other while holding
hands are you having where you had a
date exactly and your dates over in a
man
I stopped putting on that position
places
what do you guys think should clay be
adjusting his behavior or are his chill
though I see hot I have like been
casually dating someone
deme has had a lot of conversations
about her sexuality but the conversation
she needs to have at this point is with
Derek and she talks to Derek and I just
want to cheers to Derek I appreciate he
is so great and supportive and he just
listens and then he asks good questions
[Music]
like how are you thinking about that I
applaud you Derek a strong combo those
two what are you doing man dude let me
be this strong combo John Paul Jones and
tisha what do you guys think do you like
them together no matter what I'm glad
that we got JPJ as our Borromeo we've
been wondering where John Paul Jones was
and turns out he was hiding under the
two biggest pillows ever invented and
what was he doing under there
eating chicken nuggets bro it out yeah
it sort of made me feel like a young
Romeo and so I wanted to do I wanted to
share with you a poem that no he was
trying to remember a Shakespearean
sonnet from Romeo and Juliet
are you kidding me are you JP joking
it's the epithet Romeo's like recites
when he meets Juliet for the first time
to be romantic and he wants to be Romeo
and he wants to recite this to Taoiseach
what ladies it that enriches the hand of
yonder Knight for Disney that teaches
the torches to burn so bright so we get
the Bowie estonia's moment ever
he's ro me bro he's our Romeo he's ro me
man it just felt so
[Laughter]
[Music]
JP hey I loved everything about it
that's all but then we go from a chill
mode to a Oh bro a fight is breaking out
in paradise we had seen this altercation
in the trailer and I thought it was
gonna be between clay and Christian but
I should have known better because clay
is chill in it is actually Jordan oh my
god Jordan clay is a gentleman
Jordan is all my love but eject in this
moment which turn I'm really sorry
Clay's a good friend of mine he just
goes and starts a fight with Christian
so Christian is clearly ready to fight
we know cuz he'd been holding clays
hands so tight and things go down
oh my god
[Music]
next week on bachelor in paradise we
won't see it until next week we get it
to be continued what did you guys think
of this episode I loved it I love you so
much I'm on Cameo let me know what you
thought in the comments below
love you all so much we will be back
here next week got two more episodes my
JC I told you to get my favorite rose a
Lauren they run out of that rose a well
I know I drink a lot but you need to
order it ahead of time but Lauren the
factory ran out of rose a I don't think
okay I do think that it's possible that
I drank them out of my favorite rose a
but you need to be in the vineyard and
squeezing the grapes to work
love it